In this video, I've built
a sample app that has geofences
around the studios that I'm filming in.
As you build out your app, you'll likely
want to use a different geofence.
As we've explained earlier, a geofence
uses latitude and longitude and
an easy way to find the lat long for
any location is to use Google Maps.
You can either look at the URL when
you are in a particular location, and
pull the latitude and longitude from
them, or if you prefer, you can drop
a pin and then you can see the latitude
and longitude in the pop-up.
Note that it also depends
on your zoom level.
So, here I zoomed into the the top
secret military base at Area 51 and
you can see it can actually get
the latitude and longitude for
the baseball field there.
That must be where
the aliens play baseball.
Or if they're more the tennis type,
I can drop the pin here and
then get the latitude and
longitude for the tennis courts.
Yes, believe it or not,
there's a baseball field and
tennis courts in area 51.
Now if you prefer to go to
a slightly less secret place,
you can zoom in on anywhere you like,
for example the Google campus.
And here I'll find the latitude and
longitude of my favorite coffee shop,
which is right here in this building.
There's the latitude and longitude.
So it's up to you.
You can find locations wherever you like
on Google Maps, and like I said you can
either look at the URL, as you can see
here, to get the latitude and longitude,
or you can drop the pen and the latitude
and longitude will be presented to you.